hey you guys so here's something that we
decided to do since we figured that like
everyone else in the world we're kind of
not going anywhere we figured you guys
we're probably not going anywhere
because a lot of people are quarantine
and everything like that so we decided
that we would just do some fun little
videos of just random topics that we
could put up on days I told y'all was
gonna talk y'all through this yeah all
right okay some like some bonus material
it's not gonna be long maybe another 15
20 minutes a day we might do this daily
we don't know yet we're either gonna do
it we could do it daily or we could just
do it like on the three days that we
don't put anything up just so we have
something going up every single day you
know what I mean yeah well I don't know
we'll see how it goes like if we have
some [ __ ] to talk about we can just do
it you saw just current events just
whatever you know you guys are bored and
we know we might be bored too depends on
what the situation is and we'll put out
some more information yeah we can do all
that yeah
so what's on the list so the first thing
we wanted to talk about this is a
recommendation we wanna make normally I
would have probably saved this for the
matinee show because I think it came out
last year or something like that but we
just wanted we just watched it last
night and we wanted to talk about it I
don't know if you guys know but there is
a youtuber named Oliver Harper and he is
a British guy and he has a really good
movie retrospective channel he mostly
does a tease action and horror and stuff
them yeah it's professional quality yeah
well yeah he's like the best dude on the
Internet yeah and he does like a really
lot of research about the movies and
what goes in-depth and talks about them
and reviews them as well and the after
market on the movie like whether or not
they made video games and he talks about
video games and soundtracks and
everything like he has like a massive
massive collection of like movie
soundtracks and movie video games like
on all different platforms and he's very
very knowledgeable about all that kind
of stuff
yeah so he is also a professional film
maker and he made a documentary called
in search of the last action heroes
which it's yeah it's really good and we
just watched it last night we
it on Xbox right I think you can read it
on YouTube YouTube - pretty sure it's
only like $4.99 and this is just like
the ultimate it's a two and a half hour
yeah it's like two or twenty-one minutes
um discussion about the action movie
genre where it came from who was
involved you know what was the
psychology behind it and where it went
where it is now and it's just movie made
that documentary or make you cry man
brandy bring some back some memories
there's a lot of good guests that come
on at writers and directors and actors
from all these movies yeah and just
excellent excellent excellent it's if
you're if you're in the movie business
this is something that you have to see
actually yeah I don't feel recommended
it's a rob bra said right yeah you got
to see this and if you're just kind of
young and need need of kind of a
tutorial on movie culture this is
something you have to see too because
this is an aspect of American culture
that's I think it's kind of going away
it's kind of gone now I think they don't
make movies like that anymore and they
talk about it in a documentary and they
kind of explain why they don't make
movies like that anymore yeah I do feel
I mean this like I said the the
documentary is two hours and 21 minutes
and basically they start out he starts
out with you know kind of like a brief
overview of you know some of your like
Steve McQueen movies and stuff like that
and then he kind of goes into where
actual movies came from right and then
they you know in bond and stuff and then
he'll like he kind of goes into like
Bruce Lee and all the martial arts
movies and stuff and how they influenced
you know American movies now this
documentary covers a huge amount of time
and a huge amount of films so it's like
it's very fast-paced like it'll you know
it goes from one thing to another like
really quickly because there's like a
lot of ground to cover
Hong Kong theater - it's like yeah and
then ninja crazy yeah Jackie Chan he
talks about all that kind of stuff and
you know mostly it's mostly focused on
like the 80s the classic action movies
you know cannon films you know Chuck
Norris you know Arnold Schwarzenegger
all that kind of stuff so like I said
it's not you know it doesn't go in like
really in-depth into any one thing but
it's
just kind of trying to give like a broad
overview of the entire genre where it
came from like and he got like a
staggering amount of interviews yeah
with people who worked on the films he
talks like Paul Verhoeven's the guy that
directed Robocop he talks to like the
writers and you know all these [ __ ]
people like you know and even cuz like I
said he's like a soundtrack guy he
always talks about the scores and stuff
in his movie reviews which I really like
because I feel like that's kind of a
neglected yeah thing that a lot of movie
reviewers don't but I did like about
this documentary it has to be has to be
mentioned with Millennials 80s cultures
becoming kind of like in vogue for a lot
of younger people there kind of has been
for a while
yeah I'm fascinated with it especially
like new retro way of music and stuff
and you see it in new programs like
stranger things
so people that weren't even around in
the 80s are kind of enjoying 80s
nostalgia yeah well if you're one of
those you got to see this cuz this kind
of gives you a better context of what
was going on in the 80s we grew up
during that era sand man I'm so glad
that we grew up during that era I really
do like I mean it sucks being old but
it's like I do really like I like that
my formative years were then
correspondent to you know the home video
boom like MTV starting like all this
like the post-punk explosion like I
really really like you know where
everyone was starting to go like indie
and DIY and stuff and I use more
innocent time you didn't have all these
choices yeah I just had to deal with
stuff and find what was cool in what he
had and sometimes smaller is better we
weren't overwhelmed and bombarded with
information it was just it was I liked
that time that era when I go back no no
I wouldn't think so either it was it was
actually in certain ways harder like you
couldn't find what it was yeah a lot of
things are a pain in the ass especially
if you were into stuff that wasn't
mainstream
yeah like fine goth clothes couldn't
find it yeah that was the [ __ ] I had to
buy him in like Salvation are amazed I'm
now I'm go on I can go online and find
any kind of clothes yeah you get
whatever you want whatever you want and
it's easy and it's delivered to your
house in a few days wouldn't like that
back then
no no not not by a long shot but yeah I
mean you know like you said I am glad
that I grew up during that time period
but I wouldn't
go back because in a lot of ways yes
everything's more fragmented nowadays
because you know we have so many like
entertainment options that you know you
can pretty much make a studio can make
millions of dollars just like making a
movie for one particular niche audience
because they know there's enough of them
that are gonna see that and they'll make
their money back so I do feel like
that's cool because now you can there's
millions of shows there's millions of
movies there's millions of video games
and you can find exactly what you want
to play or exactly what you want to
watch like anytime you want to watch it
from your cow but another thing that was
different though is that people today
are very spoiled and jaded when it comes
to damn that's true imagery yeah cuz
there's so much of it and show it kid
anything today and they're like so what
me never recapture what it was like to
be 17 years old and watch that and be in
a theater and watch that predator take
its mask off for the first time yeah
nobody knew what predator yeah yeah and
and that that mask holds up to even
today and you just look at man that [ __ ]
looked real you had the it looked like a
real creature you had the experience as
if you were really seeing a real alien
for the very first [ __ ] time you're
just like damn and it reminds I remember
really really liking that makeup because
I was really into like and back in the
you know when predator came out I was
really into like Fangoria and I would
always buy it so it had like a fold-out
poster of the predator in it and I had
it on my wall for a really long time and
when we were watching the Oliver Harper
documentary last night and they showed
like clips of and they showed like that
that very iconic scene where he takes it
off like the first predator and I was
like goddamn 1987 that came out and that
still looks fantastic it looks like a
real monster up into that time you know
the only thing that only believable
alien I had seen was the alien from
aliens yeah anyone I don't think alien
to come out yet yeah I guess ahead alien
- it was out that was 80 when did those
around the same time maybe - well no I'm
talking about aliens yes part two
what year did that come out and Matt
can't remember but I thought the alien
looked real yeah but there was some
about that predator that it looked even
more real or it looks scarier in a way
it looked more human it had eyes yeah it
looked up you with them yeah my favorite
part is that [ __ ] jaw that one animal
that he had that I was like what it's
like a scorpion that's the only thing I
could because it looked at the man Corp
it did he was like it's like a scorpion
mouth and I think that that's what they
were they wanted to look like a person
but also kind of insectoid did you ever
seen a big scorpion eaten something
that's its mouth opens up yeah just like
yeah like an insect mandible because
they knew that that would like freak
people out if everybody's freaked out by
yeah yeah and then you see an Arnold
Schwarzenegger this big [ __ ] you
don't mean you're you're a kid you're
like man [ __ ] he's a Superman
and he's scared in the movie and getting
his ass beat
and you're just like [ __ ] and they just
can't recapture that that's what makes
that movie so good because it's like you
have a whole like a whole bunch of
badasses and they're [ __ ] their
pants right so you know that it has to
be bad right and you know fur and he was
a movie star which Millennials don't
know anything about movie stars cuz
movie stars really almost don't exist
much anymore not the way like there's
actors but it's nervous but they're not
movie stars yeah a movie star and back
in our day was like a [ __ ] rock star
yeah they were like something from a
parallel universe
they weren't even real yeah they were
like that you know I didn't have twitter
you couldn't watch them you know blow
farts or whatever you could see know who
he was hoping you knew about Arnie was
what you saw history yeah in some ways
they had like a mystique that they have
like no like I said now you can see like
these celebrities are on Twitter like
posted pictures of themselves in their
feet eepa job yeah window makeup on and
[ __ ] like that yeah yeah yeah and you
know like I said it was a more innocent
time there were you you could own
everybody knew these celebrities you're
in Oakland over these celebrities
there's are very few of them really
you might be like two or three hit girls
that year you know I mean Sandra Bullock
or some [ __ ] like that either now you
can go on Twitter and [ __ ] see girls
from all over the photo world that look
better than the movie stars yeah yeah I
mean so there's more people you can look
at now you could only look at a certain
amount of people yeah I mean days like I
said just since we didn't have all these
streaming options we didn't have the
internet we didn't have all that so it's
kind of like you had mainstream stuff
you had like underground stuff and that
was about it yeah on this couch it was
tiny yeah and it's like so when you
found another person that was into like
that had seen Eraserhead it was like it
was like wow man you're my best friend
so but it's like now there's so many
different like channels entertainment
that you can go down to like I said
there's there's celebrities that have
millions of followers millions of fans
and I don't know who they are right
because if it's a genre that I don't
follow
I mean there's too much entertainment
for any one person to like see all of it
celebrity has been democratized and hard
back in our day they were only a very
few movie stars they were like megastar
yeah like everybody World News everybody
everybody knew they were and that was
about it now it's just kind of spread
out between everybody yeah you know
which like I said in anyway we're famous
to like 100 people and then there's
millions of us yeah and it's funny it's
funny like when I you know watch like
guys that I like on YouTube you know
like Oliver Harper or you know like if
the welcome to the basement guys or you
know the guy magnet Channel Brandon 1000
they're like a Johnny [ __ ] case yes or
Dan bell or PA like that it's like when
we watch them it's like to me they're
famous but it's like if I went out and
asked some ran down the street they
don't know that is you know what I mean
even though they have like millions of
followers and like there's a there's a
niche of people that know who they are
but it's like everyone knows this
comment though you know why yeah maybe
you don't have the you don't have a
small amount of people in Hollywood
dictate to you what's cool
yeah you can choose well like I said
there's so many more options nowadays
and now that we have Netflix and we have
shutter and we have you know Disney Plus
and everything
that so now it's like you can pretty
much just pick and choose like what you
want like we like shudder because you
know I like horror and sci-fi so you can
just have that and you can just watch
all of that that you want to yeah and
you don't have to like sift through a
bunch of [ __ ] you don't want to watch no
one can dictate to you what yeah what
you mean Hollywood tries to dictate all
the time and they just fall flat on
their face people to half [ __ ] you
nobody cares it's not the way it was I
heard that at least earlier today or at
least today we're recording this I don't
know if the other major studios are
gonna do this but because so many like
movie theaters are closing and stuff
Universal said they were gonna take the
movies that they had in the theaters and
they were gonna make them available to
rent on streaming which i think is
actually a good idea I mean it's bad for
the theaters because some theaters
actually might end up closing but I'm
like what I have a feeling I have a
feeling but it's better kiss if people
want to see those movies they can say oh
man now finish it I was gonna say I have
a feeling that this event is gonna
change industries probably forever well
it probably won't go back it might is is
people are gonna say you know what I
like doing school from home why don't
why do I have to go to school to go to
school yeah [ __ ] that I just do it [ __ ]
right here and then the next thing you
know the guys that are in the schools
that own those schools are like you know
what if we were to just get rid of this
building yeah why don't we probably yeah
just sit home in their living room yeah
probably you know or you know and get
rid of all of our overheads our profit
margins it'd probably be better you know
what don't don't bring the students back
yeah just like I said I mean I [ __ ] like
dad I feel like shits been going that
going away anyway anyway just because
you know food Amazon and like you know
streaming services online schools you
know online classes stuff like that a
lot of people are like working remotely
and [ __ ] like that so I do feel like I
mean yeah this is like a big thing and
it's making everybody do that but it was
gonna happen anyway it was yeah I think
it was kind of going that way anyway the
only thing that sounds like a death
knell of a lot of these businesses that
were just kind of borderline which that
kinda sucks because it's bad that like
you know bars and restaurants had to
close like just the other night we were
supposed to go to like memento mori
which is our monthly goth night
and they decided you know after 5 p.m.
they said okay no more gatherings over
10 people or 50 people or whatever it
was so they ended up having to close and
it's like it sucks because you know you
don't know how that's gonna affect like
all the people that work there literally
like a bunch of our friends that work
there it's like what are they gonna do
now like what if they have to close for
like a month and they don't get paid the
concept of a bar or a club will survive
those are that's okay yeah I'm just
talking about like for saying those
particular ones may not make it but the
thing is is the concept of things like a
movie theater may not survive now I was
watching because if they go under why
would they replace it with a new one
yeah when when Netflix is making so much
[ __ ] money yeah you know I mean like
AMC the safer AMC for it well you know
what let's let all this [ __ ] close
instead we'll just make an app yeah and
all the people that are give us that 20
bucks a month they can keep this out and
just watch it I'll just watch it on the
stream it is it might actually go that
way I would this be better like anybody
[ __ ] can't mop the [ __ ] bathroom
floor anyway when they do mop it they
mop it with piss if you're [ __ ] they
got they got a bucket sandy no [ __ ]
men's room I just they just mop the
floor with piss the ladies room always
seemed fairly clean like when I went in
there but yeah it does seem like I was
watching um Chris stuckman made a video
earlier today he's another movie
reviewer guy and you know he was saying
it would be a real shame like a movie
because he's like I love movie theaters
and I love the whole movie going
experience but it does seem like that
business model is not yeah he's like so
he's like that would really suck if they
closed he's like but on the other hand
it's like you know all these new movies
are coming out and people want to see
them but they can't go anywhere so it
really does seem like they are charging
like um a little bit more than they
normally would like to rent the movies
but they're still like in the theatres
and you're still getting a deal because
if you if 2 or 3 people in your house
are watching the movie for 15 bucks or
20 bucks or whatever it is that's still
cheaper than going to the theater it's a
movie theaters existed and we're
everywhere in our day because they were
HD yeah ok they were HD because come on
it was all film it looked great you know
our TVs a CRT TV
was the [ __ ] low-res like crazy great
yeah it looked like as like ass and then
it was too narrow but now in our room I
have a TV that could have never been
imagined even [ __ ] twenty years and
it's not even like we don't have like a
giant now people we just have like a big
deal and it wasn't expensive either not
only you know I'm so cheap right now you
can get a damn wall sized television for
[ __ ] 500 bucks yeah yeah I mean and
we have surround sound yes with surround
sound all that Wireless [ __ ] why the
hell would you want to go to the damn
theater yeah it'd be easier just to have
an AMC app and says instead of driving
over there that's just [ __ ] play it
here it might actually like it might
actually go that way and I don't know
like I haven't checked earlier I've
heard as I said that Universal was doing
there so that would be Invisible Man
what the other two movies the hunt and
that other one but there's like so
you're gonna be in like starting Friday
you're gonna be able to watch them on
streaming just like you would a regular
movie even though they're still in the
theaters
and also one of their movies which is
like a kids movie it was like that
trolls movie that was coming out they
said that one's just going they said
they'll play it in theaters that are
still open but they're also doing it to
VOD like on the same day so you have the
option of seeing it in either place you
know what I mean so they didn't actually
push that one back they said we're just
gonna do the idea theatre at the same
time and if you want to go to the
theater if one's open near you then you
can see it there but and otherwise you
can see it up I would love just have AMC
app because you could just see whatever
channel home at the day comes out I mean
I'm rich people have had that for
[ __ ] ever yeah I know you know I mean
I do like going to the movies um you
know what I mean because I don't yes we
have like a nice TV and yes we have nice
surround sound and stuff but it's nice
to get out of house it's nice to get out
of the house and also when you go to the
movies you don't have like distractions
like in your house you got your phone
you got like people like um I have to
disagree you know why why that we're
going during the day yeah when it's
normally pretty light yeah every now and
then you were going there and it's
crowded yeah not only that got some you
know the last time we saw that Invisible
Man just a couple seats over I got this
[ __ ] nasty [ __ ] in shorts
with no shoes on with his feet up on the
[ __ ] thing you know many people do
you stinky ass [ __ ] tongue bit yeah I
mean I'd rather be at my house you know
then look at this man with my own stink
yes he's acting like he's in his [ __ ]
living room you know [ __ ] cutting farts
and [ __ ]
yeah theatre I'd rather be at my house
with a drink in my hand you know man
there's a pause it hold on gonna take a
leak yeah you had a timeout yeah I can't
do that at the theater yeah I gotta come
back Jane what happens - she's like I'm
trying to watch it so but yeah it'll be
interesting to see how things go
I mean like you said I think
everything's kind of going to anyway I'd
be sad to see theaters go because you
know this might be the end of like the
multiplex I kind of feel like I don't
think like indie theaters might still do
okay yeah I don't think theaters
themselves will disappear because from
this I think a lot of theatres who that
weren't getting a lot of action will
close they're closing well and I think a
lot of shits gonna click restaurants and
bar malls ladies [ __ ] like that well
just because because there were malls
that were struggling
those [ __ ] aren't coming back now
well yeah because no why the hell would
you want go too long you know
hardly anybody was going to oh you'd
have less chance of catching [ __ ]
Cove in 19 for a [ __ ] dead walk
there's a lot of old malls out there
need to be torn down anyway well and
like I said watch dan bells channel or
there's there's like a lot of really
good dead mall channels if you're into
that kind of stuff cuz it's really kind
of I don't know why it's so fast taking
space well I wish that they would I mean
either tear them down or turn it into
something else useful because that's a
lot of space that could be used you
should do something I built for retail I
know and the thing is is that they suck
up a lot of power just
an American dish and yeah and you can't
sell anything high-end in them anymore
it's just cheap little trinkets
something that one in Miami yeah it's
that one yeah I myself jewelry and Rolex
isn't [ __ ] but most of us just cheap
over cheap overpriced trinkets yeah I
mean it's an item that you can get off
eBay or or or [ __ ] wish for [ __ ]
you know five dollars and they want to
sell it to you for $25 yeah because it
came out it's really kind of note it is
it's kind of like vulture ISM off of
poor people yeah they don't have they
don't have them ATM cards or something
they don't have an eBay or Amazon
account so they have to go to them mall
and they walk around and then they spend
their [ __ ] on everything is expensive
because the rent is a rant and spending
their welfare check on this like an
overpriced [ __ ] Chinese trinkets so
really that that mode of retail should
go
I really wish they would do some malls
have started to do this where they go to
like mixed-use where they make them kind
of like offices office space so they
have leather like some gyms are opening
up in there I wish they would go to like
part like residential and then you know
like mixed-use they can have like some
apartments in there and then they could
open up like little cafes or they can
have like other offices in there so the
space was at least being utilized you
know it wasn't just sitting there like
[ __ ] yeah
being empty because that's shitty spam
yeah that was another thing he's like
well what are we gonna talk about I said
well let's talk about the Oliver
documentary cos that was rad he has
another one too called in search of
darkness yeah but it yeah there was like
a copy on eBay but it was like seventy
something dollars and it was used and
it's like because I wanted to rent it
because that's about 80s horror yeah
which you know that's my jam can't get
it but it seems like it's kind of hard
to get so I don't really know if it
hasn't really come out yet or that it
has Edition if anybody has it they want
to burn us a copy of it we'd love it you
can send it to us I mean I want to give
all of her money but you know if I can't
get it so you can't get it it's not for
sale because I mean we rented his other
one like Xbox but yeah so he wanted a
soy so we'll talk about the Oliver thing
and the let's to talk about spam right
I've got people [ __ ] with me about
spam I got Pro spam and anti spam is a
war a war
it gets like don't [ __ ] on spam it gets
really really butthurt get upset behind
my spam that's a first thing that
happened was she had some people talking
[ __ ] about spam I posted about spam on
Facebook and then they want to talk bad
about spam and you're lucky at in Bakke
a-- comments down a warrior is fan
powered world war two is spam power spam
is the emergent it was the original MRE
it was yeah it's like a thousand two
hundred calories of almost pure [ __ ]
protein it's pork shoulder it's not
mystery meat its pork shoulder with I
think bacon yeah and then it's it's kind
of taken off of the shoulder raw and
it's packed into the candy they put too
much salt in it back in the day it's not
salt as it was they salted it and then
it cooked it inside the can inside a
sealed can yeah its stay forever all
right the new flavored ones are good
okay the question was if somebody asked
me that for recipes on spam survival
spam for the apocalypse apocalypse
breath apocalypse fan there's some new
new rules for spam okay plain spam is
still out there it's not as salty as it
was it's okay
always slice spam and fry it or cube it
and fry it before you use it in any kind
of dish they also have some new flavored
spam all right I've got all the flavors
except turkey and I've tried most of
them there's a couple of my haven't had
yet the flavor spam is better than the
then classic spam the best ones I've had
so far is smoked smoked kind of tastes
like smoke to lunch beat kinda like
smoked ham or turkey kind of like that
next one after that would be bacon
Bacon's good it's called a bacon flavor
spam that's really good on any kind of
breakfast sandwich breakfast food you
know I mean you use it in place of bacon
yeah you keep it and like fry it with
eggs cubed fry it with eggs maybe put it
inside of a damn omelet or you can slice
it kind of thin and fry it and then put
it on a sandwich with egg and cheese
make like a make like a UH egg McMuffin
type thing
I gave I think I gave it to you on a
hamburger bun with egg and cheese
remember I don't I think it was I didn't
think that you put spam on that one I
thought there was bacon spam your plate
a bit I don't know I thought I gave to
you know maybe I maybe I just need
because she turns the [ __ ] down
but hold on look at that okay it's cuz
your she turns it down sometime whenever
I make it and I says you better
recognize okay well it should you get
hungry at you may be welcome I mean spam
a bacon and all that kind of stuff it's
just it's not so much that it's gross it
just gives me really bad heartburn
well yeah her oh I'm starving but it's
like I'm we're not domestic rival
rations we gotta save it I got it I got
a stockpile of it but every now and then
I eat I like it too and another flavor
that they had that I thought was really
good was jalapeno how opinion flavor is
very good it's good in tacos slice it
into peace prize put it in a taco shell
address it the second talk oh it's good
you could take the classic spam and cube
it and fry and then put taco seasoning
in it and yes that is taco filling too I
think something like chorizo how much I
think some people put it in ramen as
well could do that okay the other one
that I had that was good was called
black pepper it was pretty good yeah but
yeah it didn't really have the distinct
flavor one favorite one way or the other
though well I mean black pepper isn't
really I love black pepper on everything
but it's not really a flavor yeah it
wasn't really a flavor they got a turkey
one I haven't tried it I don't like
Turkey I knew I loved her and I might
like that one I didn't check the back of
the can and I'm like processed Turkey
yeah yeah and I think it's gonna be
processed Turkey but I should have
looked in the back because you know what
maybe it wasn't Turkey at all it might
have been pork pork that tastes like
turkey Turkey and it's like tofurkey
yeah but cherien
it says Turkey on it it's prolly turkey
turkey flavored pork that'd be really
what's right right it's bad [ __ ] there's
a couple of other ones on there you know
someone reformed flavors Bayona had them
yet do you know what you should do you
should do like a spam turducken
you should take like all of the spam
flavors and put one inside the other put
one inside the other and see what that
tastes like you can eat spam right out
of the can without it being brown or
fraud but it's best on crackers if you
do that it's crackers and cheese it is I
mean I will admit I'm very indebted to
better better cooked it it's already
cooked yeah it's just that it doesn't
really have any context to it when it
comes out of can because it's just been
basically boiled in a can
yeah it's kind of mushy so that's not
mushy I would say it's just it's it's
it's the texture is kind of like kinda
like salmon lunch beat yeah kind of like
kind of like it's more solid than
Bologna kind of like salami yeah that's
like the texture I've eaten it before
it's just I has good
I haven't eaten it often enough to it
now here's another thing that you have
to understand whisp and spam has a
website on that website on that website
or a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] recipes so
that's so you know I'm just giving you
ideas but if you want it but if you want
it specific recipes go to the spam
website and they have all come you know
we're at recipes that were submitted by
people that made stuff and they rise to
the top yeah the natural [ __ ]
selection rising to the top
[Laughter]
yes ma'am brought to you by Spain like I
said if we talked about him enough maybe
the I like spam goes back when I was a
kid my aunt and all my aunts going to
the damn Sequoia National Forest camp
and they have some spam cook it up on
the fire
spam pin' spam Vanina with rice you can
make all kinds of stuff with it okay
that's never spam what else we have to
talk about I think that's probably it
that's it okay we probably got on we've
gone along we've got I said this is just
like some extra [ __ ] that we're gonna
probably put up on days when we don't
have anything else going up
yeah just keep you guys see keep you
guys entertained to keep ourselves
entertained you guys I can't get
anywhere told you guys I'd talk you
through this I don't know if I'll talk
to you know if this [ __ ] goes on to
three months you guys are you can do it
come on I've known you for almost ten
years and you talked pretty much that
entire time okay what'd you guys do make
sure you if you guys have a stockpile
enough food to get you through then you
guys are dumb
I shoulda seen this [ __ ] coming we
started we started a ways back if you
got guns [ __ ] keep that [ __ ] handy
secure your area don't you know a man if
you see the cops and the cops are in
trouble you can go out there and [ __ ]
if you're able-bodied and you you know
you got balls you can go out there and
help the cops you know if you have to if
this [ __ ] goes like it goes like Katrina
you're on your own you better like I
said we still have infrastructure we
still have electricity of Internet we
still have you could panic and too much
that's what we they are the problem the
reason why Katrina went like that and I
was there at the time you know the
reason why Katrina went down that way is
cuz it was hot as [ __ ] and no one had
any power no one had any powers were
flooded nobody had you clean water fresh
water yeah and within within about three
days manifest we got a minute cometh out
there [ __ ] raping and murdering and
[ __ ] the cops or going rogue the cops
ran and it just became Robbery fest
[ __ ] you know you could if you could
steal it it was yours that was really
what happened well that's what I mean
it's like so in a lot of ways
you know this whole coronavirus thing
sucks but it's like you know kind of
count your blessings we still have yet
power we still power fresh water so a
lot wrong and honestly we went to the
grocery store yesterday like we went to
the liquor store first because
priorities guy get booze but I was like
well I need to go to the grocery I
wasn't stocking up I said I just need
some cat food and I'm a laundry
detergent so we were gonna go to Sam's
but it was kind of a zoo like that it
was a Monday but there was like a
million people in there we were like
yeah [ __ ] that I'm just gonna go to
Publix
so we went to Publix now some stuff was
sold out like a lot of the cleaning
stuff was gone like bleach and
everything a lot of soup was
gone there was still some there but it
was just I was cracking up I was mad
because it was weird they were out of
Manhattan clam chowder which is like my
favorite and I was like god damn it who
thought nobody liked that but me but
well I guess I was wrong so there was
like kind of weird flavors left I got a
I got a couple of cans but I was like
whatever [ __ ] it and most of the boxed
pasta was gone
yeah but other than that I mean the
store looked pretty normal like it
looked I mean there's food everywhere
it's not kind of loud me at least where
we are now they're making food foods
coming they're bringing it right it's
it's not like [ __ ] down it's not like
everybody's like oh my god there's not
gonna be any food anymore it's not the
zombie apocalypse yeah not a hurricane
not anything like that and they're
saying 15 days there's still food it's
everywhere they're saying they're saying
15 days and they're saying that because
you can walk around for two weeks
asymptomatic yeah so what you see today
is actually two weeks in the past yeah
so two weeks from now they'll know how
bad it is today
see see how I did that yeah so they
won't really have any [ __ ] numbers
for another two weeks
and what they're gonna do is they're
gonna look at those numbers and then
from those numbers they don't know where
it is and how bad it is
yeah no matter what guarantee is it's
not gonna be as bad as they think it's
gonna be because I don't think it was
because people because people have
stayed calm people are kind of kind of
isolating and they're kind of and that's
gonna disrupt disrupt the spread of that
hey people gonna get sick yeah it's not
that bad
all right and they just want everybody
sick it was because if you're all sick
at once oh yeah I don't think it's not
it's I don't think it's a kind of thing
where it's like oh my god no one's gonna
die it's just it's a flu I mean some
people will die but some people die from
flu every years isn't a super flu from
rain stand rain they just want people to
not you know try to keep it from
spreading just so like you said so
health services aren't overwhelmed yeah
and what they're talking about is this
everybody got sick at once then you'd
have a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of old people
[ __ ] trying to get to the hospital
all at once and all dying into damn same
time they don't want that yeah because
if they're all in there at once and you
can't treat them yeah if you could treat
them as they come and if they're coming
slowly then those little people will
live yeah that's what they're trying to
do it doesn't have much to do with
young people now yeah there was some
young people that died in Wuhan all
right but that was a doctor who was
around that [ __ ] he's being bombarded
with [ __ ] viruses from [ __ ]
hundreds of damn sick people that's a
very different environment than just you
walking around yeah very different and
yeah that's the thing it's like we're
mostly staying and in the house like I
said we went to the grocery store
yesterday but you know everyone has
everybody is pretty much chill
everybody's got we ate out at a
restaurant but everybody's got like you
know the the [ __ ] you know [ __ ] you
put on your hands before that I can't
remember the name of right now damn
restaurant in middle damn plague you're
the only one there there was one of the
guy we were talking about it he's a
Dominican Republic she's like hurricanes
I'm like right because there's no
hurricane you good and he goes tsunami
said yeah that's right cuz I'm Dominican
Republic yeah so they get like really
bad [ __ ] ah you know so they're just
kind of like I mean as long as you're
like not in a big crowd as long as you
wash your hands as long as you put the
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] on your heads
which we did when we went into the
restaurant we put the [ __ ] on our hands
and again when we right before we left
and like touch stuff with your elbows
and everything yeah you know it's it
will probably be fine you know what I
mean it's good situations gonna
normalize in about two or three weeks
people are gonna go oh this ain't it
ain't that bad and then people gonna
start going back to work and it's not
it's not gonna spread like it didn't
move on well and plus I think because
people at least they took it seriously
and they're saying okay well everybody
if you can stay home just please stay
home and it does seem like a lot of
people are doing that and you know
they're letting people work from home do
you classes or homes they're in a warmer
climate even better yeah because that
kills that virus a lot faster if it's in
a warmer climate so I think it all gets
on just objects I mean I don't know but
I I just feel like it's not gonna be a
bad eye I think after a little while I
don't know I think I'm almost half the
world's population will get it but most
of those people won't even know they're
sick yeah it's just like I said it's
it's a flu there's other there's tons of
other related viruses related kids like
that and it's gonna take probably about
three months for half the damn world
population to get it's not gonna happen
although I mean this isn't like the
[ __ ] black death or anything like
that we're like 50 million [ __ ]
people that it's not yeah it's it's
about two percent fatal but they're
talking about very fringe people dying
yeah people that were already fighting
diseases and hospitals and stuff which
you know we do have a couple of friends
that are you know that are
immunocompromised you know because they
had been undergoing like cancer
treatments and stuff but but as long as
the hospitals aren't jammed up they they
can survive it - yeah and you know and
they have to take probably more
precautions and we would like Mara
wearing masks and stuff but you know I'm
trying not to get - yeah it sucks being
stuck in the house but we were kind of
in the house your Lottie before and in a
way it's like I know this is kind of
[ __ ] up to say but it it sucked worse
I think went to be stuck in the house I
know when everybody when everybody else
was out having a good time now nobody's
out having a good time and never I'm not
missing anything because everybody home
having a good time everything [ __ ] got
it over it on the end Oh online or
talking [ __ ] about it's not the same
situation as it was because so much of
our activities online anyway yeah the
world didn't used to be that way but it
is now yeah that's what I mean you know
if you moved on I studied a half you
don't have to go go out you can still
own that goddamn little thing talking to
people and you're not you don't feel
isolated yeah it's you know so I don't
porn and [ __ ] with each other hold a
camera
why do screens are getting bigger you
can fit the whole app get a tablet
footlong tablet get the whole ass just
trying to keep it real you can see our
spending on bottles
all right you want you want to end it
yeah we got a we got a be guests on
another show yeah we're doing
conspiratorial yeah which you know this
is per this will probably go tomorrow's
I don't know when the conspiratorial
show is going to probably be a couple
weeks but yeah we got to record that in
a couple hours so we'll see you again
next time